whenever anyone talks about great teams
and eSports they usually just want to
talk about the superstars the players
who become the faces of their
organizations because time and time
again they can pull off the spectacular
can jump on those boxes but instead he's
gonna cool the frag but this is so nice
from liquid he's holding it and all not
fastened to his jacket but as often as
these gods might bask in the warmth of
the spotlight
sometimes they're known to burst into
flames when they're forced under it
vitality I'm relying on that super sauce
I wear to carry them through this round
we'll see if it can be done it's called
a shamans Eastbourne he's got it going
for it but for Andreas zip exhale if
things are a little different on the
surface a stralla tsa's soft-spoken
unassuming support player might appear
to be a background figure in the team's
incredible success but he might actually
be one of their most influential members
you see over the years zip except a
reputation for himself not for being an
outrageous personality but for being one
of the most consistent calculated and
cold-blooded killers Counter Strike has
ever seen for being the clutch minister
it'll be back-to-back rounds for G -
unless he can clutch it he's know he's
got the fix on Inferno never ceases to
amaze that's so sick what was that show
so why exactly is zip it's so effective
in these high-stakes situations where
he's completely outnumbered and is there
a method to his madness or is he just
the luckiest player in csgo as if it's
tried to work back inside of the lobby
25 HP only to work with as the bomb will
reach its logical conclusion is he gonna
go for this are they still down there oh
my god oh my god oh my clutch ministers
got a new sermon
unbelievable unbelievable from septics
he is the clutch master
okay so aside from being a four-time
major winner a grand slam recipient and
a core member of counterstrikes greatest
dynasty who is zip --ax well when he's
not terrorizing opponents on the server
this digital serial killer is actually
about his laid-back and humble as can V
he's a regular guy who enjoys family
time
ice cream and the occasional good cry on
top of having a casters nightmare for a
username zip expects is some of the most
relatable facial expressions eSports has
to offer and he's probably the most
polite Fragger you'll ever encounter on
the server however when it comes to
serious competition this nice easygoing
guy has made his name as one of CS goes
most intimidating players but how well
after kick starting his pro career with
fnatic and the copenhagen wolves in 2013
zip exchanged ignite Oz which then
became TSM forming the future core of
Astralis with Dupree and device and it
was during these years that the quiet
Dane began to establish himself as a
kind of specialist not because he was an
incredible offer had supernatural aim or
outstanding biceps no zip expel waste
man alive during losing rounds and oddly
he had an unmatched talent for routinely
turning these desperate situations into
winnable ones but this is still an
unwinnable situation now for as it makes
to find himself in a 1v3 and he's gonna
get backstabbed as well
soon as that smoke clears and upper
tunnels comes down to when Dennis
decides to push that was that was
definitely kind of you know the Hail
Mary play that much to be honest but
okay shot fifty-five seconds and so
how's that mixes once again turned it
into a 1v1 they come back to overpass
when he pulled off the 1b three earlier
he could do it again I mean Dennis is
right outside the sit mix has no way of
knowing that he's looking towards the
doors does he check the clutch 1v3 play
which sometimes call him the robot
because he seems to seem to sort of come
up with solutions then that shouldn't
really be possible you know when there's
a lot of pressure on very few seconds
left you have a lot of decisions to make
and crack it and it seems like the
answer may be a and both the phase is
filled down at B site they're gonna
stick together it isn't open a famas to
try and get rid and they're still
looking at B they seem to have thought
it would still be site for some reason
now they're gonna move in but it's gonna
be stalled attempt in zip X is gonna
pounce on this exist is gonna slowly
come up as well
cippec pulls it off over the last few
years with a straw list racking up
countless trophies and basically
redefining how counter-strike was being
played people began to take more notice
of the individual talents making up the
team and it wasn't long before zip
extension for playing the hero when all
of his teammates were dead began to
inspire a series of memes eventually
leading fans to dub him the clutch
Minister one man the man behind a lot of
the magic of Australis especially in
clutch circumstances but this one surely
too tall of an order need to get someone
on that bomb they've got the plan mother
kid defusing it no the first running out
of time running out of chances now
they've run out of smoke tax Kenny still
defusing ladies and gentlemen that is
how
what buses three it cippec's every day
of the week left to clutch now unlike
most monikers in esports this one is not
the product of exaggeration
this dude is freakishly consistent on
top of being recognized as one of the
game's best players for the past three
years
zip ecstatically secured more clutches
than anyone at big events that's right
he isn't just pulling off unbelievable
turnarounds online or at some lesser
land
he's regularly defying the odds on sea
ESCOs biggest stages he knows that
there's a player on B side he has to
fight his way out of it and it's not
going to work it's on a zip Nick's now
unreal that's why big that is big one on
three for sip but he's got the bomb in
40 seconds here the alleys already
tanked up sit there and ready ready
waiting for him right in front and they
get the timing down just moving up on
the other side of him and see if he's
gotta be turning his back at the hell -
what else the alley with the patience
play coming out flashbang is in there
now 25 seconds headshot coming in from
siblings what complain hell he do he has
to find the bomb and make his way onto a
site and look at the angle here this is
not easy ple way out in the open he gets
shot down settings for the water brave
watch oh my god one
laughs what a god I mean what more can
you ask him a guy he does everything to
support the team and then on top of that
as if that wasn't enough then he can win
you crazy 1 B 2 or 1 V 3 or even 1 V 4
situations right it's insane
the guy's got ice water for blood right
so his value is unparalleled and he
really is a complete player he maybe
he's maybe not you know coming up with
like the in scene you know simple Nico
cold device kind of place but he's an
asset to any team and he is certainly an
asset to us draw us so what exactly is
zip it's a secret well for starters luck
has very little to do with it
you see zip accentual e the
counter-strike purists wet dream he
executes the basics with an almost
machine-like discipline and his ability
to read situations and masterfully adapt
to them makes him a total nightmare for
opposition I think he's like in the
world and he has like I think people
situations because he's just smarter
than everyone else
so I think it's easier for him today to
do some touches because people is whole
thing in the situation and like I think
he loves he loves these mind games
between all the players and he loves to
be oh we're thinking and mind games is
like the key to win sip in a 1 vs. 4
Astralis they get they get what they
want but they just can't complete the
rounds you know they got what they
wanted they just didn't like what came
afterwards Sana's law just waiting and
zip nicks has picked up the bomb but
he's got nowhere to go there's no escape
route to that upper bomb site try and
work his way around 37 seconds Goodwin
four zip Nick's three kills the kolache
Minister would have to get an ace clutch
to get a straw list their second and
breeze is going to oblige him he just
walks out to the open they're gifting
them these and tip Nick's might just do
it again spots the shoulder that's a
huge win that's what they needed and tip
Nick's is the one to deliver it again
and again and again but as impressive as
if accesed act achill intelligence maybe
it's his ability to isolate himself from
his own emotions in game that makes him
a truly unique terror and to better
understand how he can do this so
effectively when the stakes are sky-high
we reached out yet again to Madison
Clark Kowski our gamer brain studying
experts at the University of
Saskatchewan Pacific's when he's in
these 1bx situations or these college
situations where he doesn't need to
worry about his teammates needs to worry
about himself there's less demands on
his working memory and his attention can
narrow and it could be that it's in
these situations of narrow detention and
that's kind of like his stimuli sweet
spot where he excels cognitively so this
could be troves effects it could just be
that in the clutches where he
essentially goes into cognitive function
overloads and performs better than he
would in other situations and he's
possibly better at that than his
teammates or a lot of other parts as
well perhaps the most unsettling thing
about civics though is the fact that
unlike the vast majority of
counter-strike players he genuinely
enjoys being in these clutch or kick
scenarios he's become so used to
actually prevailing when outnumbered
that he takes it pretty badly when he
doesn't he simply has greater positive
efficacy expectation of himself in these
situations so that literally translates
to belief in yourself so belief in
yourself you know it's scientifically
supported you know it has merit it
actually does improve your performance
because it makes you less prone to the
drawbacks of stress you've got rush
planning the bomb on just as little HP
this bomb site could have been so easily
cleared but it still could be you nose
Golden's they're based on the reload and
cippec's has now got himself into the
bomb site three kills and a bomb to get
on top of he's gonna pull the goose egg
and all automatic automatics not gonna
be a tap horse
ten-second stick of course zip X pulls
this out of nowhere
the last second but it's not enough time
you've got to wonder if there's an
element of like guys it's zip X and a1
b3 be careful and that Methos he's
created for himself strikes fear into
his opponents which ends up playing
directly into his hands so it could be
that his reputation as an insane clutch
ax my only be reinforcing this effect so
basically it could be that the CS goes
community is only making him stronger
not see him he said this after I asked
him after and he was like they know it's
if I'm the clutch and he said like I'm
gonna stand like a pretty stupid spot
because they're not gonna expect that
and honestly real anyway in spite of the
fact that zip X may never be the
flashiest player the best Fragger or the
most commanding voice in coms his
influence on astrologist sustained
success cannot be overstated he
understands what it is to play in a team
and to make sacrifices for the team
that's if nicks and and for me that's
why he's one of the greatest players to
ever play csgo is his ability I'm not
putting him up there if I cannot shear
star power we're not talking like a Niko
or a simple or anything but what I am
talking about is he's one of the best
team players out there period hands-down
he's the kind of guy I think every coach
wants on their team on their roster
because you need players like that the
selfless players who you know can make
the sacrifice for the team to perform
better because after all it is a team
game so yeah I think that's that sums up
zip mix for me he's mister reliable for
a solace now goes for the fight
immediate shutdown and falls back he
knows rain is up there kid the Norwegian
do it again waiting zip of course with a
clutch in the pistol round
counter-strike is an unforgiving game
where every decision you make can be the
difference between winning and losing
between hoisting shoddily constructed
silverware and forever wondering what it
feels like to do so and thanks to his
reliable ability to navigate that
treacherous path and comfortably manage
his own emotions zip ik says emerged as
the ultimate big game player you see at
the end of the day superstars don't
guarantee majors sometimes it's the
silent assassins who forego the
spotlight that
I'm the most when they have to step into
it or some now that it's just six he'll
step out front taco much Minister Lee :
he's got three oh my goodness tip next a
quite old until he's done s barely might
you're right he might at the time he
doesn't have a kid I think six is pull
this off I think he adds a one versus
far more on the store greatest dynasty
who exactly is civics good Wow Wow
double ring on the table that's good I
like that
wow wow wow wow wow oh yeah we have fun